so the symptoms are going to be just
like any cold or flu that you get
they're gonna be cough fever sore throat
maybe a runny nose maybe a little bit of
GI symptoms meaning nausea and vomiting
maybe some diarrhea and then shortness
of breath is the one that we worry about
in terms of pneumonia those are the main
symptoms and they overlap a lot with
influenza joining me today is an
infectious disease expert working on
pandemic policy focusing on emerging
infections and preventing bioterror dr.
amos Adal juh
welcome to the Reuben report thanks for
having me all right thanks for doing
this we're gonna try to do this in about
20-25 minutes and just pack in as much
information as possible so let's just
start coronavirus 101 what is this thing
so corona viruses are a large viral
family they cause about 25% of our
common colds and we know about we knew
about six of them four of them are
common cold viruses two were more
dangerous SARS and MERS which were
emerging infectious diseases that had a
high mortality rate the other ones just
called cause common cold but after SARS
and MERS people got very interested in
understanding are there more severe
corona viruses and what happened was in
China at the end of December they
noticed a cluster of individuals who had
an unexplained pneumonia and they
discovered a new corona virus and
because of its linkage with SARS because
they're in the same family people got
very worried and that's what sparked
this whole initial response but they're
just a viral family that causes upper
respiratory tract infections for the
most part but in some individuals can
cause pneumonia okay so can you explain
how that's actually different than the
common flu so the flu is a disparate is
a different virus it comes from a
different viral family it's the
influenza virus family and they share a
lot of similarities with coronaviruses
in terms of the fact that they cause
similar symptoms but they're very
distinct viruses and influenza is one of
our top infectious disease threats
because it's caused pandemics through
history one just about 100 years ago in
1918 filled about 50 100 million people
so flu is always on the top of our list
but we hadn't really thought about
corona viruses being able to cause
pandemics until the SARS outbreak in
2003
and while they are similar in their
clinical presentation meaning the
symptoms that they cause they're a
little bit different in their
characteristics in the sense that there
are no vaccines for coronaviruses there
are there are no antivirals for
coronaviruses and this coronavirus
doesn't seem to be a it doesn't seem to
be acting like the common cold cause and
coronaviruses meaning it's transmitting
like them but it's killing at a higher
rate probably about 10 times the rate of
what we see during seasonal flu at the
upper limit so that that's why it's a
little bit different it's more dangerous
than the average flu that you get it's
not one of those bird flu strains that
kills me 60 percent of people but it is
something that is more dangerous than
the regular seasonal flu okay so two
things there can you talk specifically
about the symptoms because we're hearing
some some conflicting information on
that and then about the transmission
part because I think that's where people
are most worried at the moment so the
symptoms are going to be just like any
cold or flu that you get they're gonna
be cough fever sore throat maybe a runny
nose maybe a little bit of GI symptoms
meaning nausea and vomiting maybe some
diarrhea and then shortness of breath is
the one that we worry about in terms of
pneumonia those are the main symptoms
and they overlap a lot with influenza
the contagiousness is that this is a
disease that's pretty contagious
compared to other corona viruses like
SARS and MERS which were scary but not
very contagious between people this is
behaving more like the other corona
viruses that cause the common cold
meaning that it can be transmitted
through coughs and sneezes and on some
of the surfaces that people have touched
if they have khakhra sneezed on their
hands that's what's making this more
scary than any of the other corona virus
outbreaks that we've dealt with in the
past this is something that transmits
very efficiently in the community and
that's why this is spreading in many
many different countries and it's not
really a containable virus because of
how easy it spreads and the fact that
many people have mild symptoms that are
indistinguishable from the cold and
they're out there doing things and
spreading this around so is that really
the number one problem that there are
probably many people that have this
right now and they simply don't know so
then they're going to the supermarket
put their hand on you know right by the
cash register or something or payment
processor and then next thing you know
they're transmitting it
that's part of the issue we know that
this virus emerged in China at least
around mid November which meant it had
been spreading probably for some time in
the community and we did there was no
restrictions or anything like that
people were traveling all over so we
know that this seed in many countries
probably before we even knew knew it and
we had a pretty severe flu season and
because the symptoms are
indistinguishable and most people have
mild cases they were probably mixed in
and not even diagnosed and they're
likely are many undiagnosed chains of
transmission in the United States that
are starting to pop up now like we saw
in in Washington State for example and
that's the issue is that we didn't know
who had this disease so we couldn't tell
them you need to isolate yourself and
protect protect yourself from infecting
others nobody did any of that in the
early stages of this outbreak and that's
what we're left with now so on an
international level it seems that
various countries are having various
success and failures with this can you
talk a little bit about why Italy seems
to be struggling so much with dealing
with the outbreak sure so Italy had an
outbreak that started out and basically
their approach was really to focus on
the severe cases they started to test
for mild cases and they actually got
criticised by their central government
for finding mild cases because it was
driving their case numbers up and it was
making people stigmatized Italy because
during an outbreak there's lots of
stigmatization that occurs for
irrational reasons usually and that's
what happened in Italy didn't really act
quick enough on those mild cases and
allowed those mild cases to spread and
then you basically have the oldest
population in the world in Italy and we
know this disease is much more severe
and those that are older and have other
medical conditions and that really has
created a crisis mode in that area of
Italy where the cases are located in the
Lombardi region and from what I
understand they're not allowed to move
those patients out of Lombardi so you've
got basically a fixed capacity of ICU
beds and hospital beds there and a
disease that's spreading very quickly in
the population in that population is
older so you've got these hospitals
inundated and and basically running out
of capacity and really in crisis mode
and in response the government of Italy
is basically locked down that entire
country yeah what about the rest of
Europe it seems like the UK may be not
doing enough at the moment but it's a
little hard to figure out who to trust
at the at the moment so the UK has done
something completely different they've
actually tried to do something called
herd immunity so they're trying to get
men
people exposed to this virus so that it
builds up immunity and they can use that
to cocoon their elderly in vulnerable
populations but it's a very risky gamble
because we don't know how are you gonna
keep the younger people compartment away
from the older people compartment
they're not there people have product
they crossover you can't really seal
those elderly away from younger people
so there's a lot of criticism going on
right now of the UK's policy to do that
and it's going to likely going it's
going to result in more cases it's
designed to do that but we don't really
think that it's going to be able to save
that that elderly population by exposing
the younger population right and what
about the American response
that's been kind of hit-or-miss there
were some early good steps and then
really bad steps the I would single out
the one thing that's the the worst thing
about this is the fact that this was a
disease that we were kind of told as a
Chinese disease and not going to be
something that we have to think about
other than with travelers when we knew
that it was not that from the beginning
because like I said earlier this had
been spreading since November and we
know that the any of this any of us
notice of this basically came in January
so it likely was already here and our
testing was so restrictive that we can
only test people if they've been to
China in the last 14 days and had severe
severe respiratory symptoms that were
considered lower respiratory tract they
couldn't do somebody that just had a
sore throat for example the mild cases
were not able to be tested and we had
this major bottleneck and testing
because it was all initially being done
by the CDC and then the state health
labs that there was a problem sending
that kid out and there was a little bit
of regulatory issues that had to be
worked out before hospitals could make
their own tests and big lab companies
can make their own tests all of that put
us really behind and all of that lead
time we might have had from the time
this appeared in China and became
recognized as a problem in China when we
got to where we are today was basically
wasted because we had no idea who had to
disease how to target our interventions
or anything like that so I think most
people assume or at the very least hope
that their governments are doing the
right thing but can you take this now
down to the personal level in the
community level
you know from as simple as washing hands
to just other techniques people should
be doing in their daily lives right now
so the first message is wash your hands
a lot touch your face less that's the
thing everybody can do now because we're
in a pandemic state we have to think
about social distancing and that's gonna
be a little bit different for every
person depending on what's essential to
them and what's not essential
starting with people who are older or
who have medical problems they need to
start thinking about their interactions
with other people and trying to limit
their risk because that's what we're
really worried about here that's what
this is all designed to help them
because if they end up getting sick in
large numbers we will crash our whole US
health care system because we don't have
the capacity to deal with that many sick
people such as what's going on in Italy
other individuals who are lower risk you
have to think about what you're doing
how you can minimize your time minimize
your contacts without completely
destroying your quality of life you
might there's you know there's some
variation on what people can and can't
do
now we're seeing governor's close bars
and restaurants and I think that's
something that you're going to see more
of because there's too much social
interaction going on in those types of
places and they end up being a nexus for
the spread of the virus but I do think
that just being common common sense you
know if you're going to the gym go at
times where there's not that not peak
hours maybe order out instead of I think
order takeout instead of sitting in a
restaurant maybe and mass gatherings are
basically being banned everywhere
because of their their risk so that's
not an issue to think about anymore but
it's that type of thing that you're
gonna have to do at least for a period
of two weeks and maybe longer to see if
we can actually blunt them respond blunt
the curve basically or flatten it out
because we don't want to exceed hospital
capacity so that the idea is let's slow
the number of the rate of infection so
that they're coming at a slower clip to
the hospital so that they don't get
overwhelmed because we're really nervous
about that that's the biggest that's the
biggest in the linchpin and are
responsive so I know that you talked
about the differences that Italy has
just in terms of the demographics and
population but I hear a lot of people
saying oh we're just two weeks behind
Italy do you think that that's a fair
estimation
if you look at the numbers we we have a
case count around what Italy had two
weeks before so I think it is something
that people are saying with some
evidence behind it I think we're gonna
start to know if we're gonna follow this
Italian type of model or we're gonna
have more of a South Korean outbreak but
it's increasing looking like it might be
a little bit of a hybrid between them
because we were not as quick with
testing mild cases and isolating them as
South Korea was yeah can you talk about
flattening the curve that seems to be
the phrase that everybody's talking
about we're seeing a lot of images on
Twitter sure sure so what we're talking
about here is the epidemic curve so
think of it like a bell curve you have a
peak in cases and then they go they peak
and they come down well we're trying and
we have a line here where hospital
capacity is you want to keep your curve
below hospital capacity even if it means
you have the same amount of cases but
you flatten it out so you never exceed
hospital capacity so that's what we're
trying to do we know that we can't
contain this virus but can we slow the
accumulation of cases to a rate that's
manageable by hospitals that's what
flattening the curve is so you don't
have this big peak you kind of have a
rolling peak that's not as not as huge
of a spike and that's that's kind of the
strategy being pursued by many different
countries now in order to preserve our
hospitals where are guys like you
turning for sensible information I see
online that seems to be the number one
thing just for the average person is we
live in a strange time where people
don't trust our institutions the way
they used to you know there's always a
lot of noise on social media I mean
where are you getting actual information
where should we point people to besides
you know interviews like this and and
things like that so obviously they're
you know if you're an infectious disease
person you kind of have your own sources
that might not be suitable for for
people in the general public but there
are good sources the CDC is actually a
very good site there's a lot of stuff on
there that you can use that's actually
vetted and there's guidance and lots of
different types of all types of
different scenarios you can imagine I
think I would also make sure that people
are looking at their local and state
health department web sites because if
something happens to them it's gonna be
local you need to know what's going on
locally and what the plant plans are
there as well and then I would say for
science stuff I recommend stat news that
the most data news is owned by the
Boston Globe it's probably the best
scientific reporting in the in the world
that's where I look at that every day
and there's another group called CID
raps CIDR AP which is at the University
of Minnesota that's the Center for
infectious disease research and policy
they also
very good news articles that are easily
digestible by the public and have a lot
of really great factual information
there yeah I know this is going to be a
sort of vague question but if you're
just the average person and you're at
home and you're doing these things and
your social distancing and you're trying
not to be out there too much I mean what
level of concern should we all really be
feeling about this right now so this is
a hard question because there's a
nuanced answer to it if I'm talking to a
patient that I just diagnosed with this
I'm gonna tell them don't worry you're
gonna be okay you're not going to die
this is something that has a very low
mortality rate in most individuals and
it's gonna be like a severe cold but
it's a very different thing when you're
talking to a hospital CEO or you're
talking to a mayor or a governor because
the sheer number of people that are
going to get infected because there's no
immunity to this is going to be so high
that even that small percentage that
needs hospital care could overwhelm our
hospital system so it's a totally
different conversation you're having I
think that's why people are
understandably mixed up because they're
hearing both of those things and they're
both true they're just different
contexts because and you have to really
have that kind of nuanced communication
because people then say that you're
you're exaggerating the risk but we're
not exaggerating the risk the risk is to
the individual is not very low but the
end of the risk to a hospital or to a
city or town is really high because
that's your number of people that will
be infected so I think when some people
hear oh there's no immunity or there's
no cure they sort of don't see an end
like how does this actually burn out so
can you explain a little bit about how
something that you can't be cured at the
moment can actually end so what may
happen is that we will see a pretty
strong first wave we might get a little
bit of a respite in the summertime it's
unclear if we will or not some
coronavirus viruses do decrease their
transmission we don't know for sure
about this one but there is some
suggestion that we might see a little
bit of decrease in transmission over the
summer but it will likely be back in the
fall I think this first wave will be bad
and then we'll have enough people
immunized by getting infected that this
won't be that much of a problem it will
be something that we have with us and it
might cause severe disease but until we
have a vaccine this is going to be with
us in the population yeah all right well
I'm trying not to overload people with
too much at once is there anything else
that we should get out in this initial
call I hope as long as this continues
that you'll be able to find a little
time for us but is there is there
anything else that you really want to
get across to people at the MoMA
Stewart sure one thing is you know this
is an emerging infectious disease
outbreaks so information is evolving so
when you see something change or some
guidance change you should expect that
because we're learning on the fly this
is real time so we're everybody in the
infectious disease field is trying to
their hardest to try and deal with this
it's become the top priority of almost
every infectious disease doctor in this
country to try and keep everybody safe
and understand this outbreak so I just
think that sometimes people get a little
they get very fixated on certain numbers
and when the numbers change they think
somebody has you know somebody's pulling
something over their eyes it's not that
it's just that this is so fluid that we
don't know what's going on even between
this call but when I started this call
with you and now I'm sure something has
happened that's changed some change one
of my answers so it's important to know
that we're doing this all on the fly
trying to use the best you know the best
of our mindset to come to a solution
here all right well listen I really
appreciate you taking the time I know
you have another hit on CNN in just a
moment and we'll link also to your
interview with sam Harris which was
really extended I wanted to give people
sort of as much as we could in a short
amount of time because I you know what I
can do is hopefully give a little
information to people and not have
everybody feel kind of crazy so I
appreciate it and as things develop
we'll reach out to you and I'll keep
trying to amplify your voice on Twitter
and the rest of it so thanks for taking
the time really appreciate it yeah thank
you for having me have run we're
obviously in some unchartered territory
with coronavirus and our plan here is to
help you make as much sense of the
situation and a non alarmist fashion as
possible if you're looking for reliable
information from experts on the front
lines of the pandemic check out our
coronavirus playlist which will keep
adding updates - right over here and to
get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe